The Joe Rogan Experience so he's showing
it to them scroll down so there he shows
it to him
that's his hog have to compare it to
these objects
he just showed him his [__] I think he's
saying it's about as big as that thing
yeah but that makes sense 13 and a half
inches but who wants that I just feel
like if he had that much I would just
hate it and say if you're walking to the
restroom or something if you have a cat
that cat's gonna attack that [__] every
time probably as you're naked
not a chance
it's a dangly little cat toy oh dude you
have to basically hold your dick up like
this when you walk over to the back
can't walk around in it oh that's like
guys with inflated balls 132 pounds
scrotum yeah that's just a disease
though right yeah but uh same problem
that he's explaining but it's a much
worse problem because like it's a
cancerous exactly it's like my 300 pound
inmate or whatever what makes their
their balls grow up that big
what do they do about those by the way
because it more than one dude is at his
balls yeah it's called the scrotal
lymphedema edema I don't think I want to
look up pictures of this yeah you do you
definitely do but let's get some
smelling salts in the system first oh
you want to yeah we're gonna look up
giant scrotums getting operated on yeah
oh Jesus let's fire up let's fire up
let's go all right let you first
oh man I've been waiting for this whoa
he requested this ladies and gentlemen
Here Comes Santa Claus right down Santa
Claus Lane take a sniff ready hit it
those are dead yeah this is dead
I think yeah that could be the older one
and this could be the newer one but even
still it's only supposed to last for
like a week or two after you open it
this one don't work
time to order some we should always have
some on the hand oh we got him got him
got him that was gonna be dead and it
was that must be our most recent one
yeah so let's Chuck this one okay
and uh oh let's order some we'll order
like five more I mean I had three I
think we've used them
here we go
Zone okay here we go boy
[Music]
[__] yeah boy it's not fresh but it's
good enough but it's strong yeah
let me get one more that's good this is
my high man that works this guy did it
to his eyes why'd he do it to his eyes
all right maybe it he's trying to did he
get rocked no he's trying to wake up to
go play probably he might have gotten
rocked I don't know I'm gonna bring
those to The Comedy Club yeah I'm gonna
take a blast before I go on stage
uh is that to catch it
supposed to go blast right before I go
on stage dude um you know where I got to
uh
oh wow I'll wake you right the [__] up
one thing that um
yeah I think there's something about
that people have an extra wiener that
makes me think it makes you angry like
the world's not fair well that's how
flat-chested girls feel and when other
girls walk by with giant tits yeah
that's a big one right because if you're
just born with giant tits you just hit
the genetic Lottery and every guy loves
big tits they all love them they have no
use for them they just want to squeeze
them they just want to suck on them some
of them are so big though yeah you can
get too big just like a dick and you're
just like God you could be like that
Canadian teacher that teaches Woodshop
classes
[Laughter]
that [__] is where woke where woke hits
its final destination dude the vet the
crazy part is that guy looks like Tim
Dylan if you just put a regular picture
of him oh yeah because he's like not
really trans it's a scam so let's see
what the operation is on this uh this
guy's sacaroony what go to oh boy that's
the Improvement look at the Improvement
the Improvement is what's on the right
oh we had nut in his legs the blockage
of lymph nodes obviously but I guess
your nut'll back up into your legs damn
uh so it goes to his legs oh oh Jesus
Christ and what do they do to drain it
I see oh look at that one it's like
necrotic look at the far left I don't
know look at that look at his butt look
at his butt oh yeah click on that it's
like his skin is dying oh Jesus how long
do you have to wait before you go see a
doctor I mean for real that seems like a
little bit of putting off yeah that
guy's guys you know he's turning into a
tortoise it looks like that guy's got
that hand green on him that's him he got
better some dudes just oh he did get
better look at him congratulations sir
but imagine just bringing a bag in and
people like what's in the bag you're
like my nuts off but hold on it looks
like they stuffed his nuts up into his
stomach yeah look
like in the left one he doesn't have a
big belly in the right one maybe as soon
as he get out he just start eating like
a pig it's like finally
well I'm sure once you can go out you
want to go enjoy yourself you want to go
to I guess but wouldn't you like
concentrate on cleaning up your [__]
Health obviously you got something real
wrong so what does it say here this is
how it started over the next nine months
every six days or so he would experience
what he felt like a sensational carpet
burn in his groin then severe cold and
shaking followed by his scrotum growing
uncontrollably larger and larger got so
bad one day that I stood in my living
room and cried he said there was a fresh
breakage of the skin and it stung to
knowing oh man he's getting [__]
stretch marks on his ball sack you ever
had like where your toe like where your
toe connects to your foot and it kind of
will crack right there yeah all the time
imagine like that happens on your nuts
yeah because your toe connects to your
foot kickboxing I would always get those
always worse because you're pushing off
with such extreme force with your toes
and your skin gets dry and things get
cracked and I was always getting slices
down there yeah I hate it I hate that it
sucked because you're walking around
your feet hurt yeah you kind of have to
walk like this you get used to it but in
the beginning you kind of have to just
walk like this
yeah
um
what else were we talking about but
dicks big dicks oh big old dicks yeah
because also people are starving in
another country and you got this big old
dick all on you right and you're fat
yeah like that guy that actor he's
eating well what is giant hog oh do you
think like 13 and a half inches I would
imagine girls like don't swipe right on
you swipe right good or what's what is
it when you choose yes it's wiping right
I'm not on the apps that's white it's
right right yeah right so I bet if you
say by the way I have a 13 half inch
dick girls be like I want that yeah who
wants that I think a lot of women would
want to see it so it's almost like come
back to my place come come back to my uh
new house come see this giant egg oh
yeah or like this like like this K like
the animals Ferrari right like what was
that then you were gonna make with the
animals yeah like a terrarium yeah
and then you just you go on the other
side of the trail even like put your
dick in like a little hole
he's got a cameo but he's definitely got
only fans right maybe he doesn't want
people to see his dick he's still an
actor you know maybe he's like still
trying to make it out in that world